in Japanese what Maria is saying roughly
translates to corpse fishing isn't very
admirable or to rummage around in a
corpse isn't very admirable and this
double entendre actually refers to the
corpse at the end of the fishing hamlet
here and while both the English and the
Japanese do imply this the Japanese
translation is way more overt about it
by saying corpse fishing this is just
one of many examples of meaning lost in
translation because when the text and
dialogue in blood-borne was translated
to English certain changes would have
been made by the localization team to
make sure that the text was palatable to
an english-speaking audience and they've
done a good job for the most part but in
a game like blood-borne even the
slightest translation that's not literal
can affect our interpretation we found
the best example of this in the old
hunters bone description the bone of an
old hunter whose name is lost it is said
that he was an apprentice to old German
and a practitioner of the art of
quickening which is a technique
particular to the first hunters what's
weird is that in the Japanese
description there is no reference of
this bone belonging to a man so it could
belong to a woman as well and I can
think of a more likely candidate can't
you this bone lies upon the grave that
transports us to the hunters nightmare
which is a nightmare full of old hunters
who possess this same art of quickening
that the bone grants our hunter so sure
it could belong to any of the old
hunters man or woman but it just makes
so much more sense if this belongs to
Maria she's linked to this grave very
heavily she was an apprentice to
Gorman's workshop she possesses the art
of quickening government had an
affection for Maria he even created the
doll in her image the doll prays at this
grave and it's the only grave to lie
just outside durman's abandoned workshop
so after looking at the Japanese
description I feel very confident in
saying that Maria is the most likely
candidate for this grave assuming this
is right we can take this assumption
further this grave exists in the waking
world meaning that Maria must have died
before Gorman's hunter's dream began and
this fact helps us put together a
timeline and tell a story
perhaps laying Maria to rest here
inspired Gorman's meeting with the moon
presence and his subsequent escape into
a dream where he created something in
Maria's image and it doesn't even matter
if this is speculation because even if
you don't agree my point is that this is
a line of speculation that we couldn't
even go down because the English
translation said the grave belonged to a
man and that's what this video is about
it's about combing through significant
item descriptions to make sure we
haven't missed anything important or to
make sure we haven't been interpreting
something wrong this whole time so if
you like me and you care about
documenting this stuff then listen along
and also let's get some love for the guy
that made this video possible
he goes by the name Law Master no jar
and he's the one who hunted down the
descriptions that I thought would most
benefit us being translated his
initiative his dedication and his
knowledge of the language is the basis
of this video so let's do something cool
for the guy and help him get his YouTube
channel off the ground he's got these
plans to create a playthrough of souls
games focusing on translations and the
law so subscribe to him if that sounds
interesting alright so back to the
translations this gender discrepancy
with the old hunters bone got me
thinking what if other English
translations have misrepresented agenda
and I immediately thought of Alfred's
dialogue where he says this once a
scholar betrayed his fellows at Bergen
worth and brought forbidden blood back
with him to cainhurst castle it was
there that the first of the inhuman
vilebloods was born
the file Bloods are fiendish creatures
who threaten the purity of the church's
blood healing lo and behold it turns out
that this betrayer isn't necessarily a
he either in Japanese this betrayer is
referred to with a gender-neutral
expression which obviously again opens
him up to being a man or a woman and who
this betrayer is has always been a bit
of a mystery we don't even know if this
betrayer is represented in game before
this video most people thought that it
was the cainhurst crow who appears in
the grand Cathedral since he uses the
old hunters bone which links him to the
workshop and he also dons the cainhurst
mask which links him to cainhurst so
it's possible he betrayed the Bergen
worth scholars and took that forbidden
blood to cainhurst to begin the vile
bloodline but now that the betrayer
position is opened up to the female cast
of blood-borne the only candidate I can
think of is Maria again but I'm open to
your ideas on this one since this is
still speculation Maria is related to
the vile blood queen so she has links to
cainhurst and she clearly has links to
the Bergen worth scholars because she
was an apprentice to gurmann and she
ended up in the hunters nightmare plus
she resents what the hunters did in the
fishing hamlet which could have inspired
her to betray the bergen worth scholars
but again there is nothing explicitly
linking her to stealing Kain hosts blood
so what I'm saying is kind of a long
shot anyway again my point is that this
long shot wouldn't even be possible
unless we discovered this mistranslation
and it is worth pointing out that we
don't know how much contact the English
translation team had to clarify
questions of gender like this so bear
that in mind the betrayer is potentially
referenced in the Japanese version of
Lawrence and Willems cutscene
think now to betray me in Japanese the
pronoun kimi and the particle mo can
mean you also so you also think to
betray me so we knew there was a split
from Bergen worth and now we learn that
they may have split before Lawrence not
just after what I also found interesting
was these lines in Japanese which say we
are made human by the blood we surpass
humanity by the blood we lose our
humanity again by the blood the notion
of surpassing humanity by the blood is
largely missing from the English quote
furthermore the adage of Bergen worth
says we urge you to fear the blood as
you proceed where the English simply
says to fear the blood speaking of fear
the horrid set explains a little bit
more about why the general populace fear
and hate the hunters in Japanese the
horrid set is actually the disguised set
worn by hunters whose job it is to blend
in with the populace and who have the
power to act and kill anyone they
suspect of being a beast the English
line these hunters are keen to early
signs of the scourge serving as the
first line of defense against its
outbreak becomes they were disguised and
precautionary hunters they didn't
overlook signs of beasts hood the next
line or perhaps when the time is right
they find signs of the scourge where
there are none becomes or they see it
necessarily where they believe it is so
the final line it just goes to show the
corner beggar is not always who he seems
becomes all people have some sort of
secrets and the implication here is that
these hunters had the church pardoned
right to kill wherever they see fit to
investigate whomever they want the
English posits them as the first line of
defense against the outbreak hunters who
sometimes see beasts hood where it
doesn't exist but the Japanese suggests
that these hunters act with impunity
uncovering the secrets of the populace
all under the preach
hence of beast hunting and it does a lot
to explain the paranoia of the populace
their fear of the church and hatred of
the hunters another armour set title
that wasn't replicated perfectly is the
tomb prospector set in Japanese this
name is actually a combination of the
word tomb and a thing that is rough or
violent or a thing that breaks open no
jaw tells us that a direct translation
would be tomb break opener contrasting
with tomb prospector which sounds really
gentle and scholarly by comparison we
know from the way that the scholars
treated the fishing hamlet that the
scholars weren't particularly gentle
with this ancient race of alien beings
and the tomb prospectors were no
exception in fact they're downright rude
in their naming of some great ones rom
the vacuous spider is actually wrong the
stupid spider the word Higuchi
means stupid or idiotic and Nadja says
that these are the words you use when
you call someone a [ __ ] or something
it carries that same social weight I
feel sorry for wrong now damn rom is
referenced by a few notes as somehow
hiding rituals when we kill him in fact
menses and their ritual are revealed to
us and we can enter their nightmare and
supposedly interrupt it since rom is
within a great lake it reminded me of
the arcane lake rune here's its
description great volumes of water serve
as a bulwark guarding sleep the japanese
clarifies that guarding sleep means
preventing the sleep from being
interrupted
which I found fitting because great
bodies of water to prevent nightmares
from being interrupted killing rom in
his giant lake allows us to interrupt
the menses ritual for example the great
body of water over the nightmare of
yharnam also guards the source of the
nightmare in the fishing hamlet
preventing us from interrupting it and
speaking of rom did you ever notice that
his corpse or a corpse of the being like
him makes up the altar in four
two vibrators this is named the altar of
despair in English but in Japanese it's
actually the altar of grief or altar of
lamentations and from the way every
Attis is positioned when we first enter
not even a growing until you hit her we
can surmise that this is an altar for
her grief and her lamentations which in
my mind sounds a little bit more
personal than the altar of despair I
assume she's despairing because ROM or
this creature has ascended without her
since she is referenced as the left
behind great one and of all the
information we do need we need more
information on the nature of the great
ones and for that we should look a
little bit closer at the umbilical cords
it's very likely that these cords are
needed to meet with the great ones worth
noting is that menses is cord says it
granted them audience with Mogo in
English but in Japanese it clarifies
that it didn't grant them an audience
rather it's described as granting them a
chance meeting similarly a note in the
lecture building says that in English
the nameless moon presence was beckoned
by Lawrence and his associates but in
Japanese there is no mention of
beckoning and it simply says Lawrence
and company's moon monster and finally
the lower Leron chalice description the
English says there are trace remains of
medical procedures in parts of ailing
and Loran whether these were attempts to
control the scourge of the Beast is
unknown there is a significant deviation
here in Japanese the Japanese says were
these procedures countering the beast
sickness or priming / causing them the
expression used for priming means
literally to begin a flow of liquid
through a pump to me it sounds almost as
if the Tamarians medical procedures
mirrored the populace of yharnam x' as
they might have also discovered blood
transfusion
the Japanese questions whether they were
trying to control the plague outbreak
with medicine or causing it with me
like is done in yharnam so yeah
interesting stuff to finish up let's
rapid fire a few translations because
they're really short and I don't need to
go into too much depth first the one
reborn translates to the ones reborn
normally Japanese doesn't PluralEyes but
the word to describe them means to
revive slash reformed slash reorganize a
group or institution that was defunct
blood echoes are translated to being
dying wishes of the blood which reminds
me of the air rune which posits that the
air is a hunter who bears the echoing
will of those before him furthermore
inside is actually enlightenment frenzy
is actually insanity blood tinge is
actually blood quality in the fishing
hamlet the wizened child is literally
translated to the infant grown old
Maria's weapon the rakuyo is named
fallen leaf and is referred to in the
game as a fairly famous blade next the
doll knows that the moon presence is in
the dream in her dialogue where she says
Oh flora of the Moon of the dream it's
clearer in Japanese that flora is the
name of the Moon presence it's curious
that she knew it existed all along when
Michael ash dies in English she says
but in Japanese he's asking a question
he's questioning whether he'll wake up
and remember anything in Japanese the
celestial dial description has a double
meaning it says it will leak a secret to
the user which is another reference to
the watery secret behind the clock in
the corruption rune we learned that what
Alfred calls vilebloods don't refer to
themselves as foul Bloods instead they
refer to themselves as the blood kin of
cainhurst the same term is used in
Annalise's lines making it clear that
vile blood is a slur preferred by their
Bergen worth rivals rune Smith Carroll
is described with more humble language
in Japanese he's called copyist carroll
his transcription of beast in english
says it is one of the first runes and
one of the first to be forbidden but in
japanese it is said that it's the first
rune to be created and the first rune to
be forbidden
no exceptions and finally we start at
the beginning of the game remember that
note that was left on the chair after
your blood transfusion seek pale blood
to transcend the hunt in Japanese it's
actually seek pale blood to complete the
hunt and the Japanese reveals that you
were the one that wrote this it wasn't
left for you by the man who did your
transfusion it was left there for you by
you and thanks for watching guys I'm
glad we could get a little bit more
information out there special thanks to
my patreon supporters who make this
stuff possible and I'll see you all
really soon
you